distribution de tracts vente des
programmes discussions avec des passants
les militants versailles et de la france
insoumise qu'on campagne une tâche
compliquée sur un territoire hostile à
la gauche ont coûté mandat pour le
travail je faisais poulet travail en
plein coeur c'est à la galerie pôle
régional de gauche venus à quelqu'un qui
a de la sympathie pour fidel castro hugo
chavez nous paraît quelqu'un d'assez
dangereux s'il était président de la
république c'est tout ce que je peux en
dire
certaines personnes s'arrêtent pour
discuter et acheter le programme de jean
luc mélenchon intitulé l'avenir en
commun nous sommes sur versailles et
donc les gens soit l'accueil très bien
parce que ça les change un petit peu de
la droite de versaillaise
sinon
on nous prend les tracts pour l'instant
et les discussions sont intéressantes
mais pas très nombreux en fait
il
chacun va voter
on se place il est difficile de se faire
entendre dans les yvelines le mouvement
de la france insoumise se tourne alors
vers les abstentionnistes une stratégie
de campagne est décidée notamment lors
des réunions les militants forment des
groupes d'appui dans chaque commune
objectif échanger sur le programme est
organisé les mobilisations crois qu'on
pourrait aller au marché bien entendu
c'est la place principale
on va rencontrer des gens tout à fait
spontanément et vie privée le roi tombe
en voilà
mettre le paquet sur les quartiers où il
ya le plus de tensions faut aussi se
former entre nos 1
d'autant plus comme je le disais il ya
beaucoup de d'adhérents qui n'ont jamais
été donc un mouvement de droite et
majoritaire c'est vrai ça on plonge ce
lien très fortement d'ailleurs
s'il y avait une proportionnelle la
gauche aurait quand même beaucoup plus
d'élus cannes en a c'est quand même
aussi le scrutin qui fait cela face à ce
phénomène politique jean-luc mélenchon
propose de convoquer une assemblée
constituante
objectif permettre aux français de
déterminer les règles institutionnelles
il reste encore quatre mois aux
militants de la france insoumise pour
convaincre les français selon les
sondages jean luc mélenchon serait
crédité d'environ 15% des voix au
premier tour